चलिए तो वी आर लाइव
नाउ
लेट्स लेट्स वेट
गाइस थोड़ी देर वेट करते हैं ओके सभी को
आने देते हैं आज के सेशन में हेलो हेलो
हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो
एवरीवन
हेलो क्या हाल चाल है
सबके चलिए सभी को जवाइन करने देते हैं एक
बार लेट एवरी बडी जॉइन तब तक मैं
अ
ओके सो हेलो एवरीबॉडी वेलकम टू दिस फर्स्ट
लाइव सेशन
[संगीत]
एंड वेलकम वेलकम एवरी बडी मे को एक बार
ऑडियो वीडियो चेक कर लेने दो सभी लोग लेट
मी चेक द ऑडियो एंड वीडियो ऑडियो एंड
वीडियो सब कुछ क्लियर है ना एवरीथिंग इज
क्लियर गाइस प्लीज लेट मी नो प्लीज सभी
लोग मुझे
बताइए एवरीथिंग गुड ऑडिबल विजिबल सब कुछ
है सही है क्लियर
है
ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट चलिए
बढ़िया बढ़िया ओके ऑल थिंग्स
ओके तो आज गाइस आपको पता ही होगा कि हमारा
आज बेसिकली डाउट सेशन है यह वाला सेशन एंड
मैं आपके डाउट्स वगैरह जो है वो लेने वाला
हूं आज के सेशन में
तो जो भी डाउट्स हैं आपके आप वो पूछ सकते
हैं आज के सेशन में वेलकम टू द फर्स्ट
फर्स्ट डाउट सेशन ऑफ फ्री बग बाउंट कोर्स
एंड ऐसा शायद आपने शायद पहली बार देखा
होगा कि एक फ्री कोर्स के अंदर में एक
डाउट सेशन हो रहा है एंड बिल्कुल फ्री
सेशन बिल्कुल कोई भी हिडन कॉस्ट नहीं एकदम
एब्सलूट फ्री कॉस्ट विथ क्वालिटी कंटेंट
क्वालिटी सब कुछ एंड देयर इज अ लाइव डाउट
सेशन फॉर यू ऑल
राइट चलिए तो यहां पे आपके जो भी सवाल है
आप लोगों के मन में जितने भी जो भी जैसे
भी सवाल है चैट बॉक्स में पुट डाउन कर
दीजिए चैट बॉक्स में डाल दीजिए एंड आई विल
बी टेकिंग दैट क्वेश्चन एंड हम उस
क्वेश्चन को डिस्कस करने वाले हैं ठीक है
काफी कम लोग अभी जॉइन हुए हैं हमारे यहां
पे अ आई एक्सपेक्ट कि कम से कम अ जो
रेगुलर व्यूवर्स हैं वो तो आ जाए अपने
डाउट्स अगर पूछने हैं उनको तो चलो यहां पे
50 लोग आ चुके हैं यहां पे ग्रेट ग्रेट
देयर आर 50 पीपल नाउ राइट चलिए बहुत बहुत
बढ़िया गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सबको गुड
इवनिंग व्हाट इज योर नेक्स्ट क्लास टॉपिक
यह तो नेक्स्ट क्लास का टॉपिक मुझे भी
नहीं पता होता है मोस्ट प्रोबेबली लाइक मे
बी कोई सर्वर साइड अटैक हो सकता है या
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक भी हो सकता है राइट
सबको गुड इवनिंग सबको नमस्ते आज टाइम चेंज
कर दिया लाइव डाउट सेशन था इसलिए टाइम
चेंज कर दिया और इसके पीछे एक रीजन भी था
लाइक आई एम शिफ्टिंग टू
नोएडा तो मैं थोड़ा दो-तीन दिन जो है वो
बिजी रहने वाला उस शिफ्टिंग के चक्कर में
एंड ट्स वई दो-तीन दिन आपका जो गैप है वह
आने वाला है उस गैप को अपॉर्चुनिटी की तरह
आपको लेना है और जितने क्लासेस हैं क्लास
वन टू क्लास 22 उसको आपको पूरी पूरी की
पूरी कवर कर देनी है कंप्लीट कर लेनी है
ठीक
है आई एम वाचिंग फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान कराची
वेलकम
ब्रदर यस डाउट क्लास है भैया डाउट क्लास
है डाउट क्लास है सर आज आप स्मार्ट लग रहे
हैं बाकी दिन क्या लगता था भाई मैं यह बता
दो पहले तो थैंक यू फॉर फ एनी हैकिंग
कोर्स डू आई नीड टू मास्टर पाइथन और एनी
कोडिंग
लैंग्वेज अगर आपको एनी हैकिंग कोर्स के
लिए नहीं आपको हैकिंग में आपको मास्टर
बनना है ना आपको ऑटोमेशंस वगैरह करने हैं
आपको अ खुद के टूल्स स्क्रिप्ट्स वगैरह
डेवलप करने हैं या कुछ लाइक इन द सेंस कि
कोई कोड्स को समझने हैं किसी कोड को समझना
है आपको आगे चलके किसी एप्लीकेशन पे
टेस्टिंग कर रही है वहां आपको कोड समझने
होते हैं लेट्स सपोज कोई पाइथन में कोड है
वहां पे जावा जावा जावा कोड है वहां पे सी
कोड है वहां तो जिस लैंग्वेज को समझना है
उस लैंग्वेज की नॉलेज तो जरूरी है बट
इनिशियल लेवल पे यू डोंट नीड एनी
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज फॉर नाउ टू स्टार्ट
साइबर सिक्योरिटी आगे चलके जब आप एडवांस
लेवल पे थोड़े जाओगे वहां पे ऑटोमेटिक
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा इसकी इंपॉर्टेंस
कितनी है ठीक
है चलिए तो यहां क्वेश्चंस लेना शुरू करते
हैं एक-एक करके जितने भी क्वेश्चंस आ रहे
हैं वी आर गोइंग टू टेक ठीक
है
ओके सर आप हेरा फेरी के राजू क्यों लग रहे
हो हेरा फेरी का राजू लग रहा हूं क्या चलो
बहुत बढ़िया यह भी सही है तारा भाई यह भी
बहुत बढ़िया है
ओके सर एक्सेसेस के लिए एंट्री पॉइंट कैसे
ढूंढे यह तो मैंने बताया हुआ है यार
एंट्री पॉइंट का मतलब क्या है आपको वो
पॉइंट ढूंढना है जहां पर आप ट्राई कर सकते
हो पेलोड्स को तो कोई भी पैरामीटर हो सकती
है हेडर्स हो रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स हो सकती है
आपके सर्च फॉर्म्स वगैरह हो सकती है या
कोई भी इनपुट फॉर्म्स वगैरह हो सकती है
जहां पर इनपुट आप दे सकते हो दैट कैन
आल्सो बी राइट तो आप कहीं पर भी वो ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हो उसके लिए ज्यादा टेंशन
नहीं लेनी है राइट चलिए व्हाट ड यू मीन
बाय कीक टूल काली लिनक्स क्या बोला भाई यह
कौन सी लैंग्वेज में थोड़ा थोड़ा हिंदी
में बोल लो या इंग्लिश में बोल लो आपकी
लैंग्वेज मुझे समझ नहीं आई ब्रदर
सर मैं फर्स्ट बार ऑनलाइन आया हूं इसमें
पूरा अभी तक आपका सेशन कंप्लीट कर लिया
मुझे एक कंफ्यूजन है एक्सस में प्लीज
प्लीज लोज प्लीज कंप्लीट स्वागत नहीं
करोगे हमारा धन्यवाद डीजे ब्रदर फॉर द
सुपर चैट
धन्यवाद क्वेश्चन यहां पे है तारीख का याद
रखिएगा आप लोग द दूसरों के डाउट्स है ना
उसको भी सुना कीजिए उसको भी सुनिए उसको भी
समझिए जितने भी दूसरे को डाउट्स आप
सुनेंगे समझेंगे उतना आप का भी क्लियर
होगा डाउट ठीक है उतना आपके भी कांसेप्ट
क्लियर होंगे
राइट
ओके चलिए यहां पे क्वेश्चन है यहां पे
तारीख का जब भी किसी साइट प एक्सेसेस पेलो
डालते हैं तो वो आईपी ब्लॉक कर देता है
इसको कैसे ठीक करें पहली बात तो आपको जब
भी कोई एक्सरसाइज ट्राई आप करते हैं तो
वहां पे आप कई सारी वेबसाइट्स जो होती हैं
बेसिकली दे आर यूजिंग डिफरेंट काइंस ऑफ
फायरवॉल्स वेब एप्लीकेशन फायरवॉल्स ठीक
ठीक है
दैट्ची मदद से आप चेक कर लो ठीक है पहले
तो आप चेक करो वफ ऑफ टूल्स के मदद से कैसे
तो तुम सर्च करो वफ ऑफ गट
हब
गब ये सर्च कर लेना ये एक टूल है टू
डिटेक्ट फायरवॉल्स तो ये देखोगे द वेब
एप्लीकेशन फायरवॉल फिंगर फिंगरप्रिंटिंग
टूल इससे आप अपनी टारगेट के ऊपर चेक कर लो
कि कौन सी फायर वल चल रही है किस तरह का
फायर वल लगा हुआ है कौन सी कंपनी जो है
कौन सी कंपनी का फायरवॉल जो है यूज हो रहा
है राइट जब तुम यह वेरीफाई कर लोगे उसके
बाद उस फायरवॉल को बायपास करने वाली
एक्सेसेस पेलोड को कंस्ट्रक्ट करो यह
तुम्हें करना पड़ेगा यह तुम ऐसे सोच लोगे
कि कि कहीं से कुछ तुम्हें मिल जाएगा वो
नहीं है हा फायर वल बायपास के मिलते हैं
तुम्ह एक्सेस पेलो जैसे तुम
फायरवॉल बायपास ऐसे सर्च किया तो तुम्हें
क्या है एक्सस फायरवॉल बायपास के बहुत
सारे पे लोट्स मिल जाएंगे राइट यहां पे जो
इन्होंने जो बग बाउटी हंटर्स हैं जो टिप्स
वगैरह देते हैं तो इन टिप्स को यूज किया
करो और खुद का भी दिमाग लगाया करो ठीक है
एक्सस फायर वॉल
बायपास वेब सिक्योरिटी ऐसे सर्च करो ठीक
है तो यहां पे तुम्हें वेब सिक्योरिटी का
बहुत सारा जो पेलोड्स है एक्सस के तुम
उसको सर्च कर लेना वहां पे जाके एंड वहां
तुम्हें बहुत सारे ऐसे पेलोड्स मिल जाएंगे
जो वहां यूज तुम कर सकते हो साथ में
तुम्हें बहुत सारे आर्टिकल्स मिल जाएंगे
थोड़ा उनको पढ़ के ना थोड़ी माइंडसेट
डेवलप करो वो वाली जो फायरवॉल बायपास करने
के लिए तुम्हारा माइंड डेवलप हो जाएगा जब
उस तरह से जब माइंड सेट डेवलप हो जाएगा तो
उस तरह के फायरवॉल के पे लोट्स बायपास पे
लोट्स को कंस्ट्रक्ट करने की ट्राई करो
एक-एक करके ट्राई करो सोर्स में देखो कि
क्या आउटपुट आ रहा है जब तुम कोई इनपुट
डाल रहे हो रिफ्लेक्ट कराने के लिए तो
तुम्हें सोर्स पेज में क्या आउटपुट निकल
के आ रहा है वो आउटपुट को एनालाइज करो
क्या चीजें वहां पे बेसिकली वैलिडेट हो
रही है किस तरह का सैनिटाइज हो रहा है
उसको समझो एंड देन उसको बायपास करने की
कोशिश करो कई केसेस में बहुत सारे फल
बायपास किए जा सकते हैं बहुत तरह-तरह के
अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें यूज करके अलग तरह की
इनकोडिंग वगर यूज करके बट जस्ट ट्राई आउट
जरूरी नहीं है आप 100% सक्सेस हो जाओगे बट
स्टिल यू कैन बी सक्सेसफुल
राइट
चलिए बबलू
कुमार ग्रेटर देन स्मल देन ब्लॉक होता है
तो बायपास कैसे करें ये यही तो काम है यार
यही तो आपको करना है यही तो आपको लॉजिक
क्रिएट करनी है ना फायरवॉल एक्सस बायपास
के राइट वो अगर आप नहीं करोगे कैसे काम
चलेगा वही तो करना है
यार
राइट ओके सर बिजनेस लॉजिक फ्लज पे आएगी
वीडियो बिल्कुल आएगी भाई टेंशन नहीं लेना
है ओके
अ प्र प्रोक्सी का ₹1 का आया है हमारा
सुपर चैट थैंक यू प्रोक्सी ब्रदर थैंक यू
सो मच आई गॉट एन एटी इन वन वेबसाइट गुड
ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट अ ऑल थैंक्स गोज
टू यू सर फ्रॉम टॉप टू एंड ऑल ऑल योर
एफर्ट ब्रॉट फ्रूट्स थैंक यू सो मच अगर आप
इतना समझते हैं अगर आपको लगता है कि हमारी
वजह से आपको बाउंट मिल रही है या आपको
वैलिड बग मिल रहा है दैट इज अ ग्रेट थिंग
टू हियर एंड इससे बड़ी बात कुछ नहीं हो
सकती है मेरे लिए इससे ज्यादा खुशी की बात
कुछ नहीं हो सकती है मेरे लिए तो बहुत
अच्छा लगा ये जान के ठीक है आई वांट टू बी
एन एथिकल हैकर वयर शुड आई स्टार्ट फ्रॉम
आई नीड सम हैकिंग कोर्सेस प्लीज टेल मी
अबाउट सबसे पहली तो साइब जेरी जो है आप
सबसे पहले तो आप कहां से स्टार्ट करें
क्या स्टार्ट करें मैंने सभी को 50 बार कम
से कम बता दिया अभी तक शायद आप लोग ध्यान
देते नहीं है आप हमारे ही चैनल पे जाइए डि
फ्रक्स अकेडमी पे हमारे चैनल पे जाइए ठीक
है चैनल पे जाएंगे तो आपको वीडियो सेक्शन
में जाना है वीडियो सेक्शन में जाएंगे
यहां पे आप नीचे की तरफ आएंगे या तो आप
प्लेलिस्ट में चले जाओ ना यार प्लेलिस्ट
में चले जाओ ठीक है प्लेलिस्ट में जाओगे
यहां पे तुम नीचे की तरफ यहां आ जाओगे एंड
देयर यू विल गेट साइबर सिक्योरिटी अ
वेबिनार्स इसको आप ओपन कर लीजिएगा यहां पे
साइबर सिक्योरिटी करियर रोड मैप एक मिलेगा
कंप्लीट वीडियो दो घंटे का एक मास्टर
क्लास है इसको देखिए आपको हर एक जो डाउट
है वो क्लियर हो जाएगी कि कैसे कहां से
स्टार्ट करना है कैसे किस तरीके से शुरू
करना है रही बात कोर्स की कि कौन सी कोर्स
लेनी चाहिए तो मैं आपको सिंपल सा एक ही
चीज सजेस्ट करूंगा एंड ये है डेनिक्स
अकेडमी की डीसी जेएसपी कोर्स जी हां यू
विल बिकम अ डिफ्रॉक सर्टिफाइड जूनियर
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल आफ्टर कंप्लीट दिस
कोर्स एंड दिस कोर्स कंटेंस एवरीथिंग यू
नीड टू बिकम एन एथिकल हैकर सर्टेनली एन
सर्टिफाइड ठीक है ना तो आप हर एक चीज वो
सीख जाते हैं हर एक कांसेप्ट यहां पे आपको
मिल जाएगा आपको यहां नीचे स्क्रॉल करोगे
तो ये सारे मॉड्यूस मिल जाएंगे बहुत सारे
बोनसेज है वो सब मिल जाएंगे तो आप इस लिंक
प जाके एंड यू कैन डेफिनेटली एनरोल टू दिस
कोर्स
मैं य पर लिंक डाल देता हूं इफ यू वांट यू
कैन गो एंड विजिट यहां कोई जबरदस्ती नहीं
है बट स्टिल इफ यू वांट यू कैन जस्ट गो
एंड विजिट
राइट चलिए और और सारे क्वेश्चन है ले लेते
हैं ओके मेरा ग्राफिक्स कार्ड खराब हो गया
है ए प अटका ह ठीक है अरे ग्राफिक्स कार्ड
खराब हो गया है हाउ टु बिकम अ वेब
पेंटेस्टर अ हाउ शुड आई स्टार्ट माय जर्नी
इन एथिकल हैकिंग प्लीज रक्षित सेम अ चीज़
मैं आपको बोलूंगा सेम आप वीडियो देखिए
साइबर हाउ टू बिकम अ साइबर और साइबर
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल कैसे बने रोड मैप जो
अभी मैंने वीडियो बताई वह देखिए प्लीज
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है साइबर सिक्योरिटी
में जॉब करने के लिए बीटेक करना जरूरी है
क्या प्रिंस पूछते हैं देखो ऐसा कुछ नहीं
है कि यू नीड टू डू बीटेक फॉर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी जॉब या साइबर सिक्योरिटी में
करियर बनाने के लिए आप बीसीए के लिए भी जा
सकते हो या कोई अदर टेक्निकल जो जिसका
बैकग्राउंड है ना व वो कोर्सेस के लिए
बिल्कुल जा सकते हो लेकिन उन सारे
टेक्निकल बैकग्राउंड जो भी टेक्निकल
कोर्सेस वगैरह हैं उन सब में
रिकमेंडेटरी प्रॉब्लम नहीं है अगर नॉन टेक
बैकग्राउंड से रहोगे बीटेक बीसीए ना कर ले
मतलब कोई टेक बैकग्राउंड से नहीं रहोगे तो
तुम्हें थोड़ी सी दिक्कत आएगी जब तुम
कंपनीज में इंटरव्यूज के लिए जाओगे तो
वहां तुम पहले ही छटनी हो जाएगी तुम्हारी
क्योंकि वहां पे वो लोग सीधा-सीधा लिख
देते हैं रिक्वायरमेंट बीटेक बीसीआई ऐसा
कुछ तो वहां तो छट जाओ तो जब तुम मौका ही
नहीं मिलेगा अपने आप को प्रूफ करने का
अपने नॉलेज स्किल्स को तो कैसे करोगे यह
भी तो है ना तो वो चीज समझनी है आपको
राइट
ओके केवल इ आस्किंग एसल इंजेक्शन में
पैरामीटर फाइंड करू करते हैं तो जनरेट
करवा उसे करू तो पेज 6 बजे देखो देखो एसकल
इंजेक्शन की क्लास जब मैं लूंगा ना बहुत
ही डिटेल बहुत ही बहुत ही इनपथ क्लास
लूंगा आपको कांसेप्ट समझ जाऊंगा अभी आपका
कांसेप्ट क्लियर नहीं है मुझे सीधा-सीधा
लग रहा है आप जब देख रहे हैं आप आपने जो
क्वेश्चन करा है ना ये सिंगल कोट वाला ये
आपका कांसेप्ट बिल्कुल भी क्लियर नहीं है
आपने जस्ट कुछ चीजें पढ़ी हैं उसके बेसिस
पे आप एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन फाइंड कर रहे हैं
मैं आपको जब बताऊंगा ना कांसेप्ट इन डेप्थ
जब कैसे एक्चुअल में होता क्या है वो वो
क्या है सिंगल कोट डबल कोट या व्हाट एवर
उससे हो क्या रहा है बैकग्राउंड में वेब
एप्लीकेशन के ऊपर जब आप डाल रहे हैं एरर
क्यों आ रही है या क्यों नहीं आ रही है
चेंजेज हो रहे कि वो सब तब आपका क्लियर हो
जाएगा वेट कीजिए स्किल इंजेक्शन की वीडियो
के लिए ठीक है ओके
सर मैंने सीओ आरएस बग फाइंड किया था लि
लेकिन एक्सप्लोइट नहीं कर पाया यह बहुत
बड़ी प्रॉब्लम है एक बात आप सुन लीजिए सभी
लोग प्लीज लिसन लिसन टू दिस यह बहुत बड़ी
इशू है जो अभी क्वेश्चन करा स्टडी टाइम ने
कि मैंने सीआरएस वनबिल फाइंड की थी बट उसे
क्लोज कर दिया क्योंकि एक्सप्लोइट नहीं कर
पाया आज के टाइम में अगर आप डायरेक्ट बग
बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स को छोड़ दे अगर आप हैकर
वन बक क्राउड या यस व है ऐसे मतलब जो बग
बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स जो प्लेटफॉर्म्स है बग
बाउंट अ प्लेटफॉर्म्स है उन पे अगर हंट
करते हैं एंड वहां किसी प्रोग्राम में
आपको कोई भी वलने बिलिटी मिलती है मैं
कहता हूं एक्सेसेस क्यों ना हो ट्राई करो
उसे इंपैक्टफुल दिखाने का ट्राई करो कि वो
सामने वाले को पता चले दिखे कि वह इंपैक्ट
है उस लेबिलिटी का अगर आप उसको इंपैक्ट शो
नहीं कर पाओगे ना वो चांसेस हैं कि या तो
आपको रिजेक्ट कर देंगे उस बग को या तो
बहुत ही कम बाउंट देके क्लोज कर देंगे
लेकिन तुम इंपैक्ट दिखा के ना देखो ये दो
दो मैं एग्जांपल देता हूं एग्जांपल को
थोड़ा समझना इस चीज को मैं आपको बताता हूं
दो रिसर्चर हैं दो बग बाउंट हंटर है
एग्जांपल है एक ने एक्सेसेस फाइंड किया
रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस दूसरे ने भी
रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस ही फाइंड किया पहले
वाले को बाउंट लगी 100 की दूसरे वाले को
लगी $500 की सेम क्यों क्योंकि पहले वाले
ने इंपैक्ट कम दिखाया था दूसरे वाले ने
उसी सेम बग के लिए हायर इंपैक्ट दिखाया था
सामने वाले प्रोग्राम को एंड दे ट्रैक
देयर अ रिपोर्ट फॉर अ हायर बाउंट तो यह
दिमाग में रखिएगा जितना ज्यादा इंपैक्ट
दिखाएंगे उतनी ज्यादा बाउंट मिलेगी ट्राई
कीजिए चेन भी करने का जैसे मैंने आपको
बताया था कि अगर एक्सएसएस मिला तो उसको
हायर प्रायोरिटी वाली हायर सीवियरिंग वाली
वनबिल जैसे कि अकाउंट टेकओवर एसएसआरएफ या
कमांड इंजेक्शन अगर पॉसिबल हो पाए वहां तक
जा पाओ तो हर एक चीज ट्राई करो चेन अप
करने की एंड आगे लेकर जाने की जितना
ज्यादा हाई अ सवेरिन ज्यादा हाई बाउंट
सिंपल सा फंडा है
एक्सस मिलते ही तुरंत रिपोर्ट मत करो मेरी
एक चीज मानो मेरी एक गाइडेंस मानो मेरी एक
टिप मानो इसको एक्सेसेस मिल गया पट से
रिपोर्ट कर दिया नहीं ऐसा मत करो एक्सेसेस
मिला और थोड़ा टाइम दो एंड उसको चें करके
हाय सीवियरिंग वलने बिलिटी की तरफ लेकर
जाओ अगर हो पाता है तो नहीं हो पा रहे फिर
रिपोर्ट कर दो
सिंपल लेट्स मेक अ डिस्कोर्स यू ऑल कमिंग
विद मी नहीं डिस्कोर्स तो नहीं बनेगा अभी
क्योंकि
डिस्कॉर्डेंट वरी अबाउट दैट वी विल अनाउंस
राइट मेटा पलटेबल इंस्टॉल होने के बाद
लॉगिन नहीं हो रहा है सर वहां देख लो मेटा
पलटेबल का लॉगिन दिया हु होता है वहां पर
आराम से लॉगिन हो
जाएगा राइट यस करेक्ट चलिए और भी
क्वेश्चंस लेते हैं यहां पे मैं कुछ
डुप्लीकेट क्वेश्चंस को एंड ऐसे क्वेश्चंस
जो रिलेटेड नहीं है उसको स्किप कर रहा हूं
ठीक है तो माइंड मत कीजिएगा क्योंकि डाउट
सेशन है जितना हमने किया है उसमें से ही
क्वेश्चन आप कीजिए या कोई और क्वेश्चन है
जनरिक कॉमन क्वेश्चन वो कीजिए ठीक है ना
जो अभी मैंने कराया ही नहीं है उसमें
क्वेश्चन करेंगे तो कोई फायदा नहीं है
क्योंकि वो किसी और के लिए काम का नहीं है
वो एक तरह से बाकी लोगों के लिए वो टाइम
वेस्ट हो जाएगा राइट
चलिए सर डॉम एक्सेसेस का एक दफा एग्जैक्ट
बता दे बेसिकली क्या होता है रिफ्लेक्ट
एक्सेस चलो डॉम एक्सेसेस प मैं ट्राई
करूंगा एक सेपरेट सेशन लाने की अगर आपको
लग रहा है ऐसा तो बट एक चीज याद रखो बस
डॉम कुछ भी नहीं है एक पॉइंटर है बेसिकली
जो एक जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड के अंदर मतलब
आपको वहां पर एक डॉम के अंदर एक विंडो के
अंदर में वह चीज एगजैक्टली
आपको अप्लाई करनी पड़ती है वहां पे एंड
देन इफ यू गेट एक्सेसेस देन यू गेट द
एक्सेसेस इस तरीके का कुछ चीज होता है
थोड़ा सा कन्फ्यूजिंग होता है बट टेंशन
नहीं लो मैं ट्राई करूंगा कि एक सेपरेट
सेशन अगर ला पाऊ तो ठीक
है हाउ टू बिकम अ रेड टीमर एंड हाउ लॉन्ग
डज इट टेक आई हैव स्टार्टेड माय जर्नी
फ्रॉम डब्ल्यू एपीडी रेप टीमर की एक रोड
मैप के ऊपर मैं ट्राई करूंगा वीडियो लाने
की कैसे एक रेड टीमर या ब्लू टीमर बनते
हैं इफ यू वांट आई विल डेफिनेटली ब्रिंग अ
डिटेल वीडियो क्योंकि छोटे से एग्जांपल पे
समझाना उतना जस्टिफाई नहीं करेगा इस टॉपिक
को एंड आपको उसमें सारी चीजें मैं बता
दूंगा ठीक है तो उस वीडियो का वेट कीजिए
सम टूल्स आर नॉट वर्किंग ऑन काली लिक्स
ऐसे कैसे यार टूल्स तो वर्क करते हैं कैसे
ऐसे कैसे नहीं कर र
अ ठीक है चलिए और भी क्वेश्चन लेते हैं
प्लीज आप लोग स्पैम मत कीजिएगा अदर वाइज
मुझे टाइम आउट करना पड़ेगा बांग्लादेश
पेमेंट प्रोसेस इंफॉर्मेशन डेफॉक्स कोर्स
अगर आपके पास इंटरनेशनल इनेबल डेबिट कार्ड
या क्रेडिट कार्ड है तो आप हमारे ऐप से
जाकर परचेस कर सकते हैं नो इश्यूज और
हमारा डेनिक्स अकेडमी पप जो है अगर बाय
चांस आपको प्ले स्टोर पे कुछ टाइम में
दिखना बंद हो गया या मिलना बंद हो गया तो
या वहां नहीं दिख रहा तो उसके लिए आपको
टेंशन नहीं लेनी है वरी नहीं करना है
सम इश्यूज आर गोइंग ऑन विथ ग प् बिलिंग
पॉलिसी जीपीबीएस एंड उसके कारण से कुछ
एप्स लिस्ट हो रही है तो हमारे वेंडर के
तरफ से हो सकता है कभी डीलिस्ट हो जाए
हमारा प तो हम उसको ट्राई करेंगे वापस से
लेकर आने का तो आप लोग घबराना नहीं बिंदास
आप लोग
रहिए ओके सो लेट्स टेक सम मोर क्वेश्चंस
प्लीज एक्सप्लेन इन इंग्लिश इंग्लिश
ज्यादा आती नहीं है भाई हिंदी इंग्लिश
मिक्स करके ही
बताऊंगा सर कितनी लेबिलिटी होती हैं ओस
टॉप 10 पढ़ लो ना 10 होती हैं बस 10 के
अंदर सारी
हैं ठीक है एविल डेविल सर आई हैव ओनली
फाइव सिक्स मंथ्स इन कंप्लीट माय कॉलेज
हाउ टू गेट जॉब आफ्टर ग्रेजुएशन क्या-क्या
आना चाहिए क्या कुछ कर अ लूं जॉब लेने के
लिए प्लीज रिप्लाई इविल डेविल अगेन मैं
आपको सेम चीज बोलूंगा गो एंड वच दिस
वीडियो ये वीडियो आपको जाके देखना है
साइबर सिक्योरिटी वेबिनार्स वाली
प्लेलिस्ट में आ जाइएगा हमारे चैनल पे या
वीडियो सेक्शन में जाके ये टॉपिक वाली जो
वीडियो है साइबर सिक्योरिटी करियर रोड मैप
फ्रॉम ़ टू प्रो इसको देख लीजिए आपके इस
सवाल का भी जवाब मिल जाएगा कि क्या करना
चाहिए ठीक
है ऐप में आपका रिसोर्स का फोल्डर में बब
शूट काम नहीं कर रहा बिल्कुल कर रहा है आप
शायद नहीं कर पा रहे अच्छे से उसको यूज
इसलिए आपका नहीं कर पा रहा है बाकी सब
लोगों के लिए कर रहा है तो ट्राई कीजिए
वापस से उसको सही से एग्जीक्यूट करके एंड
उसको सही से एक्टिवेट करने का आपका भी
100% काम करेगा इट्स माय
गारंटी ठीक
है ओके
मैं कोई हां मैं कोई यार मैं ना फुल टाइम
बग हंटर नहीं हूं यार मैं फुल टाइम बग
हंटर में बग हंटिंग वैसे भी नहीं कर सकता
बिकॉज टाइम कंस्ट्रेंट्स है टाइम इश्यूज
है एंड फुल टाइम बग हंटर अगर आपको बनना है
तो आपको हर एक काम छोड़ के यू हैव टू लीव
एवरीथिंग एंड यू हैव टू कंसंट्रेट ऑन बग
बाउंट तभी जाके आप कुछ अच्छा कर पाओगे तो
आई एम नॉट अ फुल टाइम बंट मैंने पहले ही
क्लियर कर दिया हुआ है ये चीज ताकि आपको
कंफ्यूजन ना हो ठीक है बट
जितनी आपको बेस्ट ऑफ द बेस्ट नॉलेज मैं दे
सकता हूं उतना देता हूं एंड उतनी चीजें
ट्राई करता हूं डिलीवर करने का उतना
कांसेप्ट आपका क्लियर करता हूं एंड कोई
बात नहीं यार एक टीचर अगर साइंटिस्ट नहीं
बन पाता है तो क्या हो गया उसके
स्टूडेंट्स बन जाते हैं तो आप भी एक प्रो
बग बाउंट हंटर बन जाओगे इट्स माय गारंटी
तो आप में से आज जितने लोग भी रेगुलर है
ना एंड जो बग बाउंट को सीरियसली ले रहे
हैं जो सिंसियर उसको अभी कर रहे हैं और
डेली प्रैक्टिस करते हैं दिन रात पूरा बग
बाउंट उनके दिमाग में चल रहा है आई एम
100% एश्योर्ड कि आज से 6 महीने के बाद वह
बड़े-बड़े प्लेटफॉर्म्स पे बड़े-बड़े
प्रोग्राम्स में बाउंटीज उनको मिल रहे
होंगे हॉल ऑफ फेम उनको मिल रहा होगा
स्वैग्स मिल रहा होगा उनको रिकॉग्निशन मिल
रही होगी एंड उनके लिंकडन पे यह लिखा होगा
कि हॉल ऑफ फेम
[संगीत]
लोग बहुत अच्छा करने वाले
हैं पाकिस्तान से पेमेंट नहीं होती है
वरना मैं कोस जरूर लेता आई कैन अंडरस्टैंड
ब्रदर एंड पाकिस्तान के पेमेंट पेमेंट
सिस्टम का कुछ समझ में नहीं आता है हमारे
को क्योंकि काफी सारी प्रॉब्लम्स आती है
उसको इंप्लीमेंट करने के लिए तो आप हमारे
सपोर्ट टीम पर कांटेक्ट कर सकते हैं े
नंबर आपको मिल ही जाएगा तो वहां पर आप
बिटकॉइन वगैरह का यूज अगर करते हैं तो
बीटीसी में यू कैन डू द पेमेंट्स
राइट
राधे राधे राधे राधे
ब्रदर
ओके एक्सेस कंट्रोल अलाउ में क्या आगे तो
बताओ मतलब एक्सेस कंट्रोल अलाउ के अलावा
और भी चीजें है ना क्या चीजें एटली आपने
बताया नहीं एडिटिंग रूम तो उस पर अभी बात
नहीं कर स सते हैं आपने पूरा एग्जैक्ट
नहीं बताया
ना
ओके चलिए यहां पे और भी क्वेश्चंस लेते
हैं पंकज कुमार आई एम लर्निंग फुल स्टैक
डेवलपमेंट कैन इट हेल्प मी इन बग बाउंट
एंड हैकिंग ओबवियसली देखो फुल स्टैक
डेवलपमेंट जो तुम कर रहे हो तो क्या होता
है ना कोडिंग डेवलपमेंट साइबर सिक्योरिटी
हैकिंग सब रिलेटेड चीजें हैं एक तरह से
तुम जितना डेवलपमेंट में घुस जाओगे एक तरह
से जब तुम तो तुम प्रो थोड़ा सा प्रो वाली
चीज आ जाएगी आपके अंदर ठीक है तो आपके
आपको ना
कॉम्प्लेक्शन आपको होगा तो कभी भी लर्निंग
का कोई लॉस नहीं होता है बेनिफिट ही होगा
आपको एंड साइबर सिक्योरिटी में डेवलपमेंट
का रोल बहुत ज्यादा है तो आप ओबवियसली यू
कैन गो विद
दैट फ्री में शोडाउन कैसे मिलेगा फ्री में
शोडाउन कैसे मिलेगा तो मैं आपको एक चीज
बता देता हूं
ऑफिशियल पेज आपको मिल जाएगा ये वाला सडन
एच क्य करके इनका पेज है इस इनके पेज को
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
डॉलर में लिया हुआ था तो इनको एक्सप्लोर
करते रहिएगा फॉलो कर लीजिएगा एंड ट्वीट्स
इनेबल कर दीजिएगा ठीक है ना फॉलो करके तो
जैसे मतलब यहां से आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा इस
तरीके से एंड यहां पे नोटिफिकेशन ऑन कर
दीजिएगा तो आपको जैसे ही इनका आता है कुछ
ऑफर आपको मिल
जाएगा सर अगर हम प्रो हो गए तो जॉब करें
या कुछ और बता दो बग बाउंट के अलावा बग
बाउंट के अलावा कुछ करो मत ना प्रो हो गए
तो प्रो हो गए तो बग बाउंट ही करो और जॉब
करने की जरूरत शायद तुमको ना पड़े
फ्रीलांसर बन जाओ फ्रीलांस अ बग बाउटी
हंटर बन जाओ अ आपकी रिक्वायरमेंट कंपनीज
को भी होगी इंडिविजुअल्स को भी हो सकती है
छोटी कंपनीज बड़ी कंपनी सबको हो सकती है
अगर आप फ्रीलांस बग हंटर हो तो एंड आपको
बग बाउंट से ही काफी पैसे वैसे भी मिलने
वाले हैं उन पैसों को इन्वेस्ट करो
कहीं-कहीं अच्छे जगह पे स्टॉक्स में करो
म्यूचुअल फंड्स में करो अ प्रॉपर्टी अ
प्रॉपर्टी वगैरह इन सब में रियल स्टेट
वगैरह में करो जब पैसे अच्छे आने वाले आने
लगे तो एंड देन योर मनी विल ग्रो ऑटोमेटिक
वो मनी ऑटोमेटिक ग्रो करेगी जो भी मनी आए
उसको इन्वेस्ट करना होता है ₹ को दो ₹ ₹
को ₹ 0 को 50 50 को 00 100 को हज हज को
5000 5000 को 10000 10000 को 1 लाख एक लाख
को 5 लाख 5 लाख को 10 लाख 10 लाख को 50
लाख 50 लाख को एक करोड़ एक करोड़ को 5
करोड़ पा करोड़ को 10 करोड़ एंड नहीं है
ठीक है तो आपके ऊपर है टोटली गौरव भंडारी
थैंक यू गौरव फॉर सुपर
चैट हाउ टू गेट फोन नंबर यूजिंग जीमल
अकाउंट ओंट में चले जाओ भैया ओंट की कोर्स
आ रही है उसमें देखना ओंट की आ रही है
हमारी ओंट का एक ट्रेनिंग लॉन्च होने वाला
है बहुत जल्द आप सबके लिए लाइव ट्रेनिंग
सब उसमें बताया जाएगा आप थोड़ा सा दिशा
दिशाहीन हो गए हैं लेकिन फिर भी मैंने
आपको बता
दिया सर बग बाउंट के लिए तगड़ी मेथड जीी
के ऊपर वीडियो बनाओ बिल्कुल तगड़ी मेथड के
ऊपर वीडियो मैं बनाऊंगा टेंशन नहीं लेना
है हालांकि मेथड कुछ नहीं होता जो मैं
आपको चीजें बताता हूं एक तरह की वो अभी तो
एक नॉलेज है स्किल है बट आगे चलके मैं
आपको एग्जैक्ट मेथड जो है वो ट्राई करूंगा
बताने का लेकिन आप ये बात हमेशा ध्यान
रखना कि मैं अपनी पर्सनल मेथड वो ना तो
मैं बताऊंगा ना कोई और आपको बताने वाला है
यह बात एकदम दिमाग में रखिएगा लेकिन
क्योंकि अगर मान लो कि मैं लेट्स सपोज मैं
एक एग्जांपल देता हूं मैं को एक जगह पे
जाना है मैं एक ऐसे रास्ते से जा रहा हूं
जहां से मैं बहुत जल्दी पहुंच जा रहा हूं
अगर मैं वह रास्ता डिस्क्लोज कर दूं सबके
लिए तो वह रास्ते पे भीड़ आ जाएगी एंड वह
रास्ता रास्ता रह ही नहीं जाएगा वह क्या
हो जाएगा कचड़ा हो जाएगा तो इसलिए कोई भी
बग हंटर दुनिया का कोई भी हंटर कितने भी
बड़े प्रो हैं कोई भी हो दे डोंट रिवील
देयर ओन मेथड बट दे कैन रिवील समथिंग
सिमिलर टू देम ठीक है जैसे बग बाउंट में
काफी सारे प्रोज हैं जेसन डिक्स ने नेहम
सेक ठीक है ना एंड और भी बहुत सारे हैं तो
टॉम नॉम नोम की बात कर
ले देर आर लॉट ऑफ नाम लूंगा तो नाम लेता
रह जाऊंगा तो दे आल्सो प्रोवाइड यू मेथड
लॉजी आप उनके लस्ट को भी देख सकते हैं अदर
वाइज मैं खुद भी लेकर आऊंगा
राइट
चलिए सर आपके वीडियोस रेफरेंस के लिए क्या
बग हंटिंग शुरू कर सकते हैं अरे बिल्कुल
करो भाई अरुण कुमार इसलिए तो वीडियोस है
यार अरे बिंदास करो इतना टेंशन नहीं लेने
का करते
जाओ
ओके यस पल्लव यस यस मेरी कराएगा पल्लव
मेरी कराएगा
वॉइस स्लो है वॉइस यार स्लो तो नहीं लग
रही है मुझे वॉइस कहां स्लो है भाई थोड़ा
और माइक को ऊपर कर लेता हूं
क्या सर वो वीडियो मैंने देख ली है अभी बग
बाउटी प्लेलिस्ट फॉलो कर रहा हूं बट यह
पाछ मंथ एफिशिएंटली कैसे यूज करूं सर पाछ
मंथ्स एफिशिएंटली जो यूज करना है ना बग
बाउंट के लिए ही करो बग बाउंट में घुस जाओ
सारी लपस प्रो फिगर को खत्म कर दो टी एचएम
ट्रा हैक मी को खत्म कर दो हैक द बॉक्स को
खत्म कर दो हमारी वीडियोस को देखो मीडिया
ए के आर्टिकल्स पढ़ो
[संगीत]
twittersignin.com देयर आर मल्टीपल
रिसोर्सेस अवेलेबल उनको आप एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए आपको मैं एक टूल के बारे में बता
देता हूं यहां पे बहुत शानदार टूल है यहां
सर्च कीजिएगा
साइबर गो टू
google.ca के धुरंधर लोग लगे हुए हैं तो
ये टूल एक ऑल इन वन टूल है आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे हमारे टूल में 49 फॉक्स आपको
दिख रहे होंगे 265 स्टार्स दिख रहे हैं
दिस टूल इज अ अमेजिंग राइट यहां पे 10
वाचिंग राइट नाउ यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
मतलब ये टूल शानदार है ये टूल क्या है इज
ए ओपन सोर्स टूल ओपन सोर्स एंड फ्री टूल
बाय टीम डि फोनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी द टूल
इज अ टूल एट फर्स्ट इज डेवलप्ड बाय अ टीम
ऑफ स्टूडेंट्स एज पार्ट ऑफ देयर इंटर्नशिप
एंड इट इज अ कंप्लीट रिसोर्स ऑ फॉर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी क टी ठीक है ना मतलब इसमें
आपको हर एक चीज एक जगह पे मिल जाएगी जो भी
आपको चाहिए भाई सीधी सी बात है इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के टूल्स लेबिलिटी एनालिसिस वेब
एप्लीकेशन एनालिसिस पासवर्ड अटैक्स उसके
बाद नीचे आ जाओगे यहां पे वायरलेस अटैक्स
एक्सप्लोइटेशन स्निफिंग पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन पन टेस्टिंग एंड बग बाउंटीज
ये सब कुछ तुम्हें बहुत सारे टूल्स जो है
उनके राइट अप्स चीट शीट्स एंड देयर आर
मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट यू विल बी गेटिंग इन
दिस टूल एंड अभी 3.0 वर्जन जो अपडेट आएगा
उसमें आपको बहुत कुछ इस टूल के अंदर मिलने
वाला है है तो प्लीज डोंट डोंट फॉरगेट टू
यूज दिस टूल थर्ड वर्जन को जल्दी ही जब
रिलीज होगी तो उसको जरूर यूज कीजिएगा
उसमें बहुत सारी और चीजें ऐड हो हो चुकी
है बग बाउंट के लिए स्पेशली हमने बहुत कुछ
ऐड किया है थर्ड वर्जन में जो लच होने
वाला है तो आपको मजा आ जाएगा आप कोई भी
टूल को जो भी टूल में यहां पे लिस्टेड है
जैसे मान लो ए मैप है मल्ट है या जो भी है
इस टूल के अंदर ही यूज कर सकते हैं उसको
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं एंड मल्टीपल चीजें
कर सकते हैं देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स एंड
एक एक
रिकमेंडेटरी हम थ्री वर्जन में देखने को
मिलेगा जैसे अगर मान लो इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग रेकन कर रहे हो अब आपको तो नहीं
पता ना कि कौन से टूल अच्छे हैं रेकन में
रेकन के लिए देर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स मान लो
सब डोमेन नमरे के लिए देयर आर मल्टीपल
थिंग्स बट आपको ये नहीं समझ में आ रहा है
कि कौन सा टूल यूज करें राइट मतलब ये नहीं
समझ में आ
रहा ओके व्हाट इज हैपनिंग एम आई लाइव
गाइस यस आपको ये नहीं समझ में आ रहा कि
कौन सा रेकन का टूल अच्छा है तो हम वहां
पर कुछ टूल्स को रेकमेंडेड सेक्शन में डाल
देते हैं रिकमेंडेशन आपको वहां पर दिखेगा
तो वो टूल्स सबसे ज्यादा यूज या पॉपुलर या
ज्यादा अच्छे टूल्स है तो उनको आप यूज कर
सकते हो राइट यहां पे बेसिकली टीम टीम डिफ
के तरफ से यह
है या ट्स इट चलिए तो यह आप चेक आउट कर
लीजिएगा जरूर से और भी क्वेश्चन चलो ले
लेते हैं यहां
पे ओके ओके ओके
ओके
सर मैंने आपको लिंकन पर मेंशन किया था
मिस्टर केक्स के नाम से प्लीज रिस्पांस
बिल्कुल केक्स ब्रदर एब्सलूट आई विल रिस्प
[संगीत]
चलिए तो यहां
पे और स कोई सा भी मेंशन तो मुझे कहीं दिख
नहीं रहा आई डोंट नो बट पेज का मेंशन होगा
शायद तो मैं देख लेता हूं एक बार पेज
मेंशन में अगर आपका है तो कुछ लेट्स सी ले
गो टू द एक्टिविटी लेट्स सी इफ समवन इ
यहां प शमीम का है ओके यहां पे है मिस्टर
केक्स का मेंशन है लेट्स सी व्हाट ही हैज
मेंशन अबाउट
ओके एक्साइटिंग न्यूज आई रिसेंटली हैड
अपॉर्चुनिटी टू टेस्ट माय कॉलेज वेबसाइट
कंटेंस वैल्युएबल इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट
स्टूडेंट्स एंड टीचर्स इंक्लूडिंग फीज एंड
अदर डिटेल्स ड्यूरिंग माय टेस्टिंग आई
डिस्कवर्ड अ सिग्निफिकेंट वनबिल इन द
लॉगइन पेज आई इमीडिएट रिपोर्टेड दिस टू द
वेबसाइट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स एंड दे वेर
एक्सट्रीमली ग्रेटफुल फॉर माय फाइंडिंग्स
दे एक्सप्रेस देयर एप्रिसिएशन इवन दो दे
कुड नॉट प्रोवाइड अ बाउंट इट फील्स
अमेजिंग टू कंट्रीब्यूट टू द सिक्योरिटी
ऑफ़ सच ए इंपोर्टेंट प्लेटफॉर्म आई कैन सी
माइ सेल्फ ग्रोइंग इन द फील्ड ऑल
क्रेडिट्स गो टू द मेंटर डिफ्रॉक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी आई वुड रिकमेंड एवरीवन टू कम
जॉइन अस द जर्नी ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट
चलो बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया
ग्रेट ओके सो बढ़िया है यहां पर आपको एक
वैलिड बग मिला है चाहे वह कोई सा भी बग हो
डजन मैटर ठीक है ना मिस्टर केक्स
कांग्रेचुलेशन टू यू फाइंडिंग बग इन योर
कॉलेज वेबसाइट ट्स ग्रेट
चलिए सर आईम इन बिग प्रॉब्लम क्या
प्रॉब्लम है भैया बताइए मुझे वट प्रॉब्लम
प्लीज लेट मी
नो डीसी जीएसपी कोर्स में आप ही लेक्चरर
है बिल्कुल मैंने ही कराया भाई पूरा डीसी
जीएसपी मैं ही हूं उसमें टेंशन नहीं लेनी
है डीसी जीएसपी में मैं ही
हूं सजेस्ट सम बुक्स प्लीज सजेस्ट सम
बुक्स प्लीज वेब एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स हैंडबुक
ले लीजिए बहुत शानदार बुक है वेब
एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स हैंडबुक अगर आपको बुक
सजेस्ट करने के लिए बोल रहे हो वेब
एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स
हैंड
बुक ठीक है दिस बुक शानदार बुक बहुत ही
शानदार बुक दिस बुक यू कैन परचेज ओबवियसली
कंडल प्राइस ₹ 412 एंड पेपर बैक ₹5000000
एप्लीकेशन एंड कंप्लीट समझना है आपको
अटैक्स वगैरह के वेब अटैक्स के बारे में
तो यह बुक जरूर आप ले लीजिएगा ठीक है बहुत
ही अच्छी बुक है ये
चलिए अ वेलकम
वेलकम
वेलकम फोन किसी ने चुरा लिया है मेरे
बोर्ड चल रहे है उसमें मैं कुछ हेल्प नहीं
कर सकता एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी ब्रदर फोन चोरी
हो गई है तो आप जाइए साइबर से में
कंप्लेंट कीजिए या पुलिस पुलिस में
कंप्लेंट कीजिए इसमें हम हेल्प नहीं कर
सकते कुछ भी एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी सर एक्सेसेस में जब हम पेलोड डालते
हैं तो वो कैसे हम पता करेंगे कि यह पेलोड
यूज़ करने से इसका पॉपअप आएगा और इसका
इसका इस पेलोड डालने पे अगर पॉपअप आता है
तो इस पेलोड से क्या इंपैक्ट हो सकता है
लोजन आपने एक्सस की आई थिंक वीडियो जो है
वो कंप्लीट नहीं देखी है एक-एक लाइन वाइज
लाइन नहीं देखी आई थिंक आपको वापस से वो
रिवाइज करना चाहिए ठीक है आप जाके उस
वीडियोस को एक्सस वाली जो वीडियोज हैं
उनको पूरा एक-एक सिंगल सिंगल सेकंड देखिए
एंड आपको सब समझ में आ
जाएगा
ओके बुक्स के बारे में अगर आपको जानना है
तो मैंने इस पे ऑलरेडी शॉर्ट्स भी बनाया
है गाइस आप लोग पूरा कंटेंट को फॉलो नहीं
करते ना इस वजह से आपके बहुत सारे
क्वेश्चंस रह जाते हैं शॉर्ट सेक्शन में
आएंगे डिक्स अकेडमी पे थोड़ा सा नीचे की
तरफ स्क्रॉल करेंगे ना यहां थोड़ा सा नीचे
करेंगे नीचे नीचे हल्का नीचे हल्का सा
स्क्रॉल करेंगे हल्का सा स्क्रॉल करेंगे
यहां पे स्क्रॉल करेंगे यहां पे स्क्रॉल
करेंगे स्क्रॉल करेंगे यहां स्क्रॉल करते
हैं स्क्रॉल स्क्रॉल यहां पे स्क्रॉल करते
हैं यहां पे स्क्रॉल करते हैं यहां पे
स्क्रॉल करते हैं यहां पे स्क्रॉल करते
हैं यहां पे स्क्रॉल करते हैं आई
थिंक बुक्स का ऊपर र गया
क्या ये रहा यहां पे सबसे लास्ट में आ जा
एंड यहां पे 10 मस्ट हैव साइबर सिक्योरिटी
बुक्स ये आपको मिल जाएंगे यहां पे फोटो पे
मत जाइएगा थोड़ा अजीब सा फोटो है क्योंकि
मैंने रात को वीडियो शूट की थी एकदम से
नींद से उठ के तो 10 मस्ट हैप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी बुक्स इस पे आ जाइएगा एंड यहां
पे आपको बुक्स की जो है पूरी लिस्ट मिल
जाएगी मैं यहां पे इसको अभी पॉज कर देता
हूं एंड शायद डिस्क्रिप्शन में मैंने डाल
रखा होगा ये यहां पे एक भाई ने कमेंट भी
किया है चलिए बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद इन भाई का
मैं इनका कमेंट पिन कर देता हूं ताकि बाकी
लोगों को पता चल जाए तो यहां पे आपको
बुक्स के ये नाम जो है यहां पे देखने को
मिल जाएंगे हालाकि डिस्क्रिप्शन में शायद
होगा बुक का नाम डिस्क्रिप्शन में है क्या
नहीं है ठीक है तो कोई बात नहीं यहां पे
ऑलरेडी यहां पे पिंड है तो यू कैन जस्ट गो
एंड चेक आउट दिस ठीक
है नमस्ते
इटस नहीं अभी हमारी वेबसाइट पर टेस्ट मत
कीजिए क्योंकि अभी हमारा वेबसाइट खुद ही
बेसिकली हमारी वेबसाइट खुद अभी मेंटेनेंस
मोड में है अगर मैं आपको दिखाऊं डि
फोनिक्स इ करेंटली इन मेंटेनेंस मोड तो
अभी करेंटली मत आप टेस्ट कीजिए क्योंकि
अभी बहुत सारी ना उसमें बग्स ऑलरेडी है
एंड अभी हमने कोई बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम चालू
नहीं किया है तो आपको कोई रिवॉर्ड भी नहीं
मिलेगा बट हम हॉल ऑफ फेम बहुत जल्द
स्टार्ट करेंगे तो वी विल इनफॉर्म
राइट बक बाउंट क्लास कब तक कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा यह तो मुझे भी आज तक नहीं समझ में
आया मुझे भी अभी तक नहीं पता कि बक बाउंडी
क्लास कब तक कंप्लीट हो जाएगा बट मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली 20224 में कंप्लीट हो जाना
चाहिए 2024 दिसंबर तक कंप्लीट हो जाना
चाहिए
शायद
हां फ्री है पीडीएफ में तो फ्री मिल जाएगा
पीडीएफ में कोई भी बुक फ्री मिल जाएगी ठीक
है ना कोई बुक बुक अगर आपको फ्री में
चाहिए थोड़ा सा वैसे टाइप से मतलब थोड़ा
सा पीडीएफ ड्राइव पर चले जाइएगा पीडीएफ
ड्राइव इ अ
गुड डेस्टिनेशन यहां पर वेब
एप्लीकेशन हैकर
हैंडबुक यह सर्च कर लीजिएगा आपको शायद
यहां भी मिल जाएगी तो यहां पर आपको
बेसिकली इसका पीडीएफ फॉर्मेट जो है वो मिल
जाएगा आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे अ वेब
एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स हैंडबुक यहां पे आपको
मिल चुका है राइट तो आप इसको यहां से अ ले
सकते हैं यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं डाउनलोड
करने का ऑप्शन आपको मिल जाएगा एंड
डेफिनेटली यू विल गेट द गेट अगर आपको
पीडीएफ वाली में दिक्कत नहीं दिक्कत नहीं
आती तो पढ़ पढ़ते हैं तो ठीक
है सर आईडी आर की और वीडियोज आएंगी नहीं
आएंगी भाई आईडी हो गया यार मैं कंसेप्ट
समझाता हूं मैं आपको सारा वो चीज नहीं
करता ना मैंने आपको बोला ना आई एम मोर
बिलीवर इन द कांसेप्ट थिंग कांसेप्ट सिखा
दिया ना अब आप आगे बढ़ो एक्सप्लोर करो
उसको एक्सपेंड करो अच्छे से और ज्यादा
उसपे दिमाग लगाओ और नई चीजों को ट्राई करो
गैदर करने की एंड सीखने की ठीक है हैकिंग
में जॉब कैसे ले क्या सर इसका इंटर्नशिप
होता है हैकिंग में जॉब तभी मिलती है जब
आपके पास वो स्किल्स है स्किल्स अच्छे हैं
तो मिल जाएगी नहीं तो नहीं
मिलेगी पेड बैच की सर पेड बैच का डाउट
सेशन कब होगा न्यू कोर्स लिया है जल्दी
होगा टेंशन नहीं लेना है आपका नेक्स्ट वीक
मोस्ट प्रोबेबली आपका उसका डाउट सेशन हो
जाएगा ठीक है जब भी होगा
सर मैंने बुक्स का पीडीएफ डाउनलोड करके
प्रिंट करवा लिया काफी सस्ते में पड़ गया
वाह क्या बात है यह क्या बात है बुक का
पीडीएफ को प्रिंट आउट करके निकलवा लो कम
में पड़ जाएगा हा यह बात भी सही है बट आई
डोंट नो यार कैसे कैसे कम में पड़ेगा मुझे
समझ नहीं आ रहा 914 पेज है टोटल 94 पेज है
पर पेज कितना का करता है प्रिंट अगर
प्रिंट करेगा कोई मुझे लगता है ₹ कर जाएगा
तो इनटू हां तो कम ही पड़ेंगे शायद मेरे
ख्याल से कम ही पड़ेंगे जहां तक मुझे लग
रहा है इनटू 2 हां 1800 लाइक यस ओरिजिनल
से तो कम में पड़ेंगे
आपको 40 पैसे तो फिर तो बहुत कम में हो
जाएगा और भी क्वेश्चंस लेते हैं यहां पे
सर जब बहुत टूल्स यूज करके सब डोमेन फाइंड
करता हूं उसके बाद वर्चुअल मशीन में काली
का नेटवर्क काम नहीं करता है बेसिकली जब
पिंक करता हूं तो उसका रिप्लाई नेम फेलर
रेजोल्यूशन ये सीधा सीधा बात है आपका
नेटवर्क क्लॉगिंग होता है बेसिकली ट्रैफिक
क्लॉगिंग हो जाती है एंड उसकी वजह से होता
है
दैट्ची एंड थोड़ा टाइम गैप दे दीजिए थोड़ा
थ्रेडिंग का यूज कीजिए थ्रेडिंग का यूज़
करेंगे तो ज्यादा बेटर होगा आपके लिए
थ्रेडिंग का यूज कीजिए मल्टीपल थ्रेड्स
यूज कीजिए मल्टीपल वर्कर्स को यूज कीजिए
एंड देन ट्राई आउट कीजिए
राइट
ओके
डिजिटल ओसन पर टमक्स यूज कर सकते हैं क्या
टमक्स अगर किसी ओस के अंदर में यूज करने
के लिए बना हुआ है तो आप डेफिनेटली यूज कर
सकते हैं आई डोंट यूज टमक्स ना तो मुझे
टमक्स से ज्यादा कुछ खास लगाव है ना ही
मैंने ज्यादा कुछ एक्सप्लोर किया है तो
अगर टमक्स किसी ओस पे यूज चलता है स्टैंड
अलोन तो ओबवियसली कर सकते हैं क्योंकि आप
डिजिटल ओसन पे क्लाउड सर्विस यूज करें
उनका क्लाउड मशीन में क्लाउड में एक ओएस
चला रहे हो और कुछ नहीं कर रहे तो
ओबवियसली यू कैन
डू
ओके और भी कुछ सवाल देखते
हैं सर इंजेक्शन और ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल
में कौन-कौन सा अवेलेबिलिटी है यह मैंने
पिछले क्लास में भी बताई थी और आपको ओस
टॉप 10 पढ़ना है मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला
है और मैं बार-बार बोलूंगा अगर आप
ओस टॉप 10 इसको अगर आपने नहीं पढ़ा सही से
और इसकी समझ आपको नहीं है तो आप वनबिल को
कैटेगरी इज करने में कंफ्यूज कर जाएंगे
एंड आपसे वनबिल कैटेगरी इज नहीं हो पाएंगी
सही से तो आपको मैं एक आपसे मैं एक एक
विनती करता हूं रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं आप लोग
सभी लोग ओस टॉप 10 को पढ़िए 2017 का भी
पढ़ लीजिए 2017 में कैसे नंबरिंग थी
क्या-क्या चीजें थी और 2021 में क्या
अपडेट्स हुई हैं उन सबको पढ़िए पढ़िए
ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल के अंदर क्या है
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फेलियर के अंदर क्या
इंजेक्शन के अंदर कौन-कौन सी वलने
एबिलिटीज आती है सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फिन
के अंदर कौन-कौन सी आती है उसको यहां से
आप पढ़ सकते हैं राइट जैसे आप सिक्योरिटी
मिस कॉन्फिन है यहां पे तो आप इसको ओपन
करेंगे तो यहां पे आएंगे तो आपको बहुत
सारी डिटेल्स यहां पे मिलेंगी लाइक
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको बहुत सारी चीजें
यहां प जानने को मिल जाएगी यहां पे
ओवरव्यू में आपको बहुत सारा जो है जानने
को यहां पे मिल जाएगा प्रिवेंशन का यहां
पे मिल जाएगा और भी बहुत सारी चीजें हैं
वो आपको मिल जाएगी राइट तो प्लीज रीड
इट वच प्रोफाइल आई कैन जॉइन एज अ फ्रेशर
इन रेड टीम एंड आल्सो आई एम सीएस
सर्टिफाइड एनी सजेशन इफ यू आर अ सीएस
सर्टिफाइड लेट्स सपोज अ मुझे लगता है
लाइक
अ यू शुड डेफिनेटली फर्स्ट ट्राई हैंड्स
ऑन ट्राई टू फॉर अ ब्लू टीम जहां तक मुझे
लगता है रेड टीमिंग के लिए जा सकते हो
ओबवियसली
दैट्ची नहीं है बट मैं मानता हूं ऐसा कि
यू शुड डेफिनेटली फर्स्ट गो फॉर द ब्लू
टीम राइट एंड देन यू कैन गो फॉर एनीथिंग
एल्स एंड रही बात देयर आर मल्टीपल मल्टीपल
प्लेट रोल्स एंड मल्टीपल लाइक जॉब रोल्स
फॉर ईच ब्लू एंड रेड टीम ठीक है आप
बेसिकली देखो सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट का जॉब
अगर रोल है आपके पास तो आप सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट में आप क्या चीजें कर रहे हो
डिपेंड करता है कंपनी में जैसे मैंने एक
मैं क्या हूं मैं एक कंपनी हूं एज अ कंपनी
मैंने एक सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट को हायर
किया लेट्स सपोज नाउ इट्स माय ड्यूटी
व्हिच डिपार्टमेंट आई हैव टू हैंडल राइट
सिंपल सा चीज है मैं उससे क्या करवा रहा
हूं आई कैन मतलब मैं उससे कुछ भी करवा
सकता हूं तो ये डिपेंड करता है
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के ऊपर भी एंड डिपेंड करता
है आपके स्किल सेट्स के ऊपर में तो वो
स्किल सेट्स आप वो करो बट मैं ये मान के
चलता हूं
कि आप पहले स्टार्टिंग में रेड टीम ब्लू
टीम यह चीजें मत देखा करो व्ट आई हैव टू
मतलब रेड टीम करना है कि ब्लू टीम करना है
आप जो स्किल्स है वो डेवलप हो चुकी है अब
आप अपनी उस स्किल्स के बेसिस प उस कंपनी
के अंदर जाओ एंड दे विल डेफिनेटली कैटेगरी
इज यू फॉर रेड और ब्लू टीम वो आपकी
स्किल्स के अगर आपका ऑफेंसिव अप्रोच
ज्यादा बढ़िया है तो ओबवियसली यू विल बी
गोइंग फॉर द रेड टीमिंग अगर आपका डिफेंसिव
अप्रोच ज्यादा बढ़िया है तो यू विल बी
जॉइनिंग द ब्लू टीमिंग सीधी सी बात है ठीक
है
ओके क्या लाइ बग हंटिंग भाई डाउट सेशन चल
रहा
है विल योर साइबर सिक्योरिटी कोर्स मेक मी
बिगनर टू एडवांस ऑफ प्रो सीध सी बात है आप
बिगनर से प्रो बन जाएंगे बट वो आपके ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है टोटली आपके कैपेबिलिटीज के
ऊपर है हमने कांसेप्ट डिलीवर किया हमने
क्वालिटी प्रोवाइड की ट्रेनिंग कोर्स के
थ्रू अब आप उसको कैसे ग्रैब कर रहे हो
कितना ग्रैब कर रहे हो कितनी डीप जा रहे
हो कितना एक्सप्लोर कर रहे हो प्रो बनना
उसके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है
किसी के भी कोर्स किसी की भी ट्रेनिंग
किसी का भी मेंटरशिप किसी को प्रो नहीं
बनाता है मैं अगर आपको बोलता हूं ना कि
मैं आपको बग बाउंट बग हंटिंग में प्रो बना
दूंगा तो इसका मतलब यह होता है कि आप में
से जो खुद से सेल्फ एक्सप्लोर करेंगे एंड
मेरी बताई हुई चीजों पर मेहनत करेंगे
एक्सप्लोर करेंगे उसको और भी ज्यादा डीप
जाएंगे वही प्रो बनेंगे सब नहीं बन सकते
जितने भी सीखते हैं सब नहीं बनेंगे इस बार
तो मैं भी आपको डायरेक्टली बोल रहा हूं तो
जो डिजर्विंग है जो कर रहा है ना वो बनेगा
अगर सब कर रहे तो सब बनेंगे ए सिपल
एट ठीक
है
ओके डुप्लीकेट से कैसे बचे डुप्लीकेट से
तो खैर कोई नहीं बच पाया है तो आप तो नहीं
बच सकते तो यह मत सोचो कि डुप्लीकेट से
कैसे बचे यह सोचो अपनी मेथड को यूनिक कैसे
बनाए ऑटोमेटिक डुप्लीकेट हट जाएंगे ठीक है
यूनिक बनाओ बाकी लोगों से बाकी जो बाकी जो
प्रोचे होते हैं दूसरों के उससे थोड़ा हट
के सोचो हट के अप्रोच करो देन आपका
डुप्लीकेट्स का चांस कम हो
जाएगा आई विटनेस प्रोसेस अनएक्सपेक्टेडली
क्लोज विथ स्टेटस वन यह एरर आ रहा है
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग में कोई बात नहीं इस एरर को
गिट पेज आई विटनेस के पेज प जाइए इश्यूज
में डालिए इस एरर को एंड वहां से आपको
इसका सलूशन मिल जाएगा आप लोग सेल्फ आप लोग
थोड़ा सा खुद के अंदर वो लाइए प्रॉब्लम
सॉल्विंग स्किल्स प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग
स्किल्स अगर नहीं होंगी तो फिर बहुत
दिक्कत होगी वो डेवलप करना बहुत जरूरी
है सर आप एंड्र ए और एपीआई टेस्टिंग भी
सिखाओ बिल्कुल एंड्र ए एंड्र पेन टेस्टिंग
का ना हम अलग से कोर्स लेकर आएंगे क्योंकि
बहुत ज्यादा डीप चीज है वो तो व आपको
अनाउंस किया
जाएगा ओके लाइव बग हंटिंग करो सर कभी-कभी
लाइव बग हंटिंग तो हम वैसे क्लास में
सिखाते टाइम भी बहुत चीजों में कर लेते
हैं बट या अलग से भी लाइव बग हंटिंग
करेंगे हम अलग से भी लाइव बग हंटिंग का भी
क्लास आएगा आपका लाइक हम लाइव बंडिंग
करेंगे साथ में मिलकर करेंगे डेफिनेटली
करेंगे एक प्रोग्राम को चूज करेंगे लाइव
हंट करने की कोशिश करेंगे
राइट
चलिए एक्सप्लोइट ी के एक्सप्लोइट को कैसे
यूज करें डाउनलोड करके देखो सिंपल सा है
पाइथन का एक्सप्लोइट है रूबी का है जैसे
जो एक्सप्लोइट है उसको डाउनलोड करो उसे
चला दो पान का एक्सट है पान से चला दो
उसको ए सिंपल बस चल जाएगा यह तो इजी है
यार कैन आई लर्न पेन टेस्टिंग विद बग
बांटी मतलब स्टार्ट तो कर ही सकते हो पहले
स्टार्ट तो करो सीखो तो
सही
[संगीत]
अ सर जी व एक कंप्लेंट है आपकी जो नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी वाला कोर्स है फ्री वाला व
1.5x स्पीड पर है कुछ समझ नहीं आता उसमें
तो उसको थोड़ा कम कर दो ना भाई उसमें जो
ट्रेनर है आपके आयुष सर है आपके ट्रेनर वो
थोड़ा फास्ट बोलते ही हैं उनकी वो नेचुरल
चीज है तो उसको स्लो कर दो ना स्पीड यार
उसमें स्लो करने का ऑप्शन होता है
वाह अहिंसा परमो धर्मा धर्म हिंसा तथ हो
जा क्या बात
है सर न्यू टॉपिक पढ़ते हैं बट नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक पढ़ते पढ़ते पीछे वाला भूल जाते हैं
क्योंकि प्रैक्टिस नहीं होती ना यह तो
बहुत कॉमन चीज है जब आप किसी चीज की
प्रैक्टिस नहीं करोगे ना तो जब आप नई
चीजें पढ़ोगे सीखो ना तो पुरानी चीजें भूल
जाओगे इसलिए मैं बोलता हूं प्रैक्टिस
करोगे तभी परफेक्ट बनोगे ये कहा हुआ जो
सही है ना बिल्कुल प्रैक्टिस मेक्स समवन
परफेक्ट वो बिल्कुल सही है कबका परफेक्ट
बनना है तो यू नीड टू डू प्रैक्टिस
प्रैक्टिस के बिना परफेक्शन कभी नहीं आएगी
ओके साइबर टेक विद निखिल सर मैंने कुछ
स्कूल कॉलेज की साइट पे एसकल इंजेक्शन वने
बिटीज फाइंड कि है एंड कुछ में एडमिन पैनल
बायपास भी की है तो इसे रिपोर्ट करना
चाहिए या नहीं कांटेक्ट अस ईमेल पे
बिल्कुल रिपोर्ट कीजिए एंड आई होप कि आपने
कुछ वहां पे कोई भी रंग इंटेंशन आपका नहीं
रहा है आप उनको यह भी चीज मेल में बताइए
कि आई हैव नॉट डन विथ एनी रंग इंटेंशन एंड
आई एम रिपोर्टिंग दस दिस टू एथिकली ताकि
आप इस चीज को सॉल्व कर पाए एंड कोई भी
मेलिश अटैकर या कोई भी मशियल जो है उसका
यूज करके एक्सप्लोइट करके एंड कुछ बड़ा ना
कर पाए कुछ ऐसी चीजें आपकी कुछ इलीगल
चीजें ना कर पाए कोई डाटा ना ले पाए ट्स
व्हाई मैंने आपको रिपोर्ट करा है अब आपकी
मर्जी है आगे क्या एक्शन लेना
है
शांके शांके आप अपनी टे ग्रा आईडी दे दो
मैं वहां पर आपको मैसेज कर दूंगा
शांके सर क्या हम पूछ सकते हैं कि आपने
कितना स्ट्रगल किया है कॉलेज से अब तक
यहां पे शमीम ने एक लि मीडियम का आर्टिकल
का वो लिंक दे दिया है मैं ओपन करके दिखा
देता हूं यहां पे बेसिकली हाउ हैकिंग इन
टू माय यूनिवर्सिटी वेबसाइट चेंज्ड माय
लाइफ फॉरएवर सो ओबवियसली यू कैन गो एंड
रीड आउट दिस आर्टिकल रिटन बाय मी एक-एक
लाइन यहां पे मैंने मतलब एक-एक चीज को
विजुलाइज करके जो हुआ था वो लिखा है तो यह
मेरा स्ट्रगल बहुत ज्यादा तो मैं नहीं
बोलूंगा कि बहुत बड़ा स्ट्रगल था कोई
लेकिन हां था अपने आप में था एंड
यूनिवर्सिटी के अंदर कैसे जो लाइक
यूनिवर्सिटी के अंदर कैसे वल्नरेबल पहली
फाइंड की किस तरीके से चीजें आगे बढ़ी
कैसे एक ट्रांसफॉर्मेशन हुआ मेरे करियर के
अंदर में तो आपको यहां से व पता चल जाएगा
एंड आई थिंक एवरीवन शुड शुड डेफिनेटली
ट्राई ट्राई एंड ट्राई कीप ट्राइक्स
मिलेगा मैं इतना ही जानता हूं तो ओबवियसली
यू कैन
गो वेलकम
वेलकम हाय अभिला कुछ नहीं चल रहा डाउट
सेशन चल रहा है बढ़िया चल रहा है
सब सो शांके आप अपनी टेलीग्राम आईडी दे
दीजिए ताकि वहां पे कांटेक्ट हो
सके अपनी टे ग्रा यूजर नेम दे
दीजिए सर आई एम फ्रॉम बलूचिस्तान एंड
फिलहाल मोबाइल पर ही आपके वीडियोस को फॉलो
कर रहा हूं जल्दी पीसी लेने वाला हूं
फिलहाल सब चीजें टमक्स पे ही प्रैक्टिस कर
रहा हूं बहुत बढ़िया ठीक है अच्छी बात है
अगर आप टमक्स पे कर रहे हैं
दैट्ची
ट्स टोटली नॉट गुड ठीक है ना लॉन्ग टर्म
के लिए आपको एक पीसी जरूरी है तो आप उसको
ट्राई कीजिए ले लेने की ठीक है टट वड बी
ग्रेट थिंग ओके चलो ठीक है शांके
ओके विपुल सिंघल नाम है आपका शांके इज इट
विपुल
सिंगल आपका विपुल सिंगल के नाम से आ रहा
है
जशन ओके
जशन ओसेंट कोर्स कब आएगा अभी डिल फॉरन में
हूं ओसेंट फॉर साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
यह कोर्स ट्रेनिंग लाइव ट्रेनिंग बहुत
जल्दी लच होगी बहुत ही अफोर्डेबल प्राइस प
बहुत ही कुछ उसके अंदर आपको सिखाया जाएगा
साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन को माइंड में
रख के वह ट्रेनिंग आपके सामने लेकर आया
जाएगा राइट तो बहुत जल्द आने वाली है उसकी
अनाउंसमेंट बस वेट कीजिए तो शांके मैंने
आपको मैसेज कर दिया है टेलीग्राम पर आप
उसको आप उसी के रिप्लाई में डिटेल सेंड कर
सकते हैं थैंक यू सो
मच बिना रिकन के हो जाएगा टी नहीं यार
कैसे होगा कैसे होगा आई नो टेक बैकग्राउंड
इफ आई लर्न एथिकल हैकिंग कैन आ गेट साइबर
सिक्योरिटी जॉब आफ्टर ट ओके एज हाजी इ
आस्किंग कि उनके पास टेक बैकग्राउंड नहीं
है तो भी क्या उनको जॉब मिल जाएगी देखो
मैं आपको एक क्लियर कट सिंपल सा चीज बताता
हूं बग बाउंट या कोई सा भी टॉपिक कोई सी
भी सेक्टर में चले जाओ अगर तुम्हारा टेक
बैकग्राउंड नहीं है ना तो तुम्हें
प्रॉब्लम तो होगी थोड़ी सी थोड़ी सी
इश्यूज आएंगे तो इसलिए आई रिकमेंड टू हैव
सम टेक बैकग्राउंड टू हैव बग बाउंटीज राइट
तो ताकि टू टू गेट जॉब इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी वो टेक बैकग्राउंड होगा तो
ज्यादा आपके लिए इजी हो जाएगा फ्लो इजी हो
जाएगा नहीं होगा थोड़ा सा कम कॉम्प्लेक्शन
आएगी थोड़ी सी टफनेस आएगी थोड़ी सी आपको
लाइक स्ट्रगल करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि मैं
मिला हूं ऐसे लोगों से जिनका बैकग्राउंड
नॉन टिक रहा है एंड आज वो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी
में काफी अच्छा कर रहे हैं तो दे आर डूइंग
ओनली बिकॉज ऑफ देयर पैशन एंड डिटरमिनेशन
तो वो आपके अंदर है तो आप नॉन टेक में भी
बहुत कुछ कर सकते हैं बट फिर भी स्टिल अगर
आपके पास मौका है चांस है टेक बैकग्राउंड
का कुछ करने का तो आप प्लीज वो कर लीजिए
लव फ्रॉम वेस्ट बंगाल थैंक यू
पल्लव ताहिर इज आस्किंग सर मैंने सीच
वर्जन 12 किया है बट मैं उससे ज्यादा कुछ
सीख ज्यादा कुछ नहीं सीख पाया जितना आपकी
13 वीडियोस में सीख गया हूं आई विल ऑलवेज
ओ यू फॉर एवरीथिंग आई लर्न फ्रॉम डिफर
निक्स थैंक यू सो मच ताहिर मुजावर एंड
आपने ये बहुत बड़ी बात बोली है कि आपने
सीच वर्जन 12 में उतना कुछ नहीं सीखा
जितना आपने बग बांटी के वीडियोस में अभी
तक सीख लिया है एंड ट्स व्हाई आई ऑलवेज से
एंड हमारी कंपनी का यही मोटिव है कि
क्वालिटी जो है ना वह टॉप मोस्ट
प्रायोरिटी पर होने वाली है ठीक है एंड
अफॉर्डेबिलिटी के साथ दोनों ही चीज
प्रायोरिटी क्या होगा अफॉर्डेबिलिटी एंड
क्वालिटी यह दो चीजें आप सबके लिए एंड आई
थिंक वी विल टेक अप ऑन अदर ब्रांड्स अदर
प्लेयर्स इन दिस मार्केट तो हमें उन परे
टेक अप टेक अप करना है अब उसके लिए कुछ भी
करना पड़े वो करेंगे
राइट बग बाउंट रेड टीम ब्लू टीम में क्या
डिफरेंस है शॉर्ट्स अगर आप नहीं देखते तो
प्लीज आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है देखिए शॉर्ट्स
इसमें मैंने ऑलरेडी वीडियो बना दी है
शॉर्ट्स पे आप लोग सही से कंटेंट को फॉलो
क्यों नहीं करते यार मैं आपसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं आप लोग पूरे कंटेंट को
फॉलो कीजिए जिस जिस क्रिएटर को फॉलो कीजिए
ना आप उसके हर एक चीज को फॉलो किया कीजिए
आपको ज्यादा सीखने को मिलेगा अभी रिसेंटली
मैंने रेड टीम ब्लू टीम के बारे में बहुत
डिटेल में अच्छे से बताया यहां पे शॉर्ट्स
में आप इसको जरूर देखिए रिसेंट आपको
शॉर्ट्स में यह चीज मिल जाएगी
राइट मोहम्मद मोमिन हेलो सर हाउ आर यू
टुडे आई एम गुड ब्रदर हाउ आर यू
कैन आई मेक 10 लाख एवरी मंथ डूइंग पार्ट
टॉप पार्ट टाइम यहां तो फुल टाइम में नहीं
बना पा रहा हूं मैं यार तुम तुम पार्ट
टाइम में 10 लाख बना लोगे महीने के मतलब
बहुत सही है यार बना सकते हो यार अगर
तुम्हारे अंदर कैपेबिलिटीज है तो बना भी
सकते हो कोई कोई ऐसी कोई नीड नहीं है कि
मैं नहीं बना पा रहा तो तुम नहीं बना सकते
तुम तुम बना सकते हो डेफिनेटली सो 9 पीएम
तक ही डाउट सेशन रखेंगे उसके बाद क्लोज कर
देंगे वन आर का ही मेरे पास लाइक विंडो था
आज का क्योंकि मैंने आपको बताया आई एम अ
शिफ्टिंग टू नोएडा एंड
दैट्ची करनी है तो
अ बहुत जल्द आई विल बी इन नोएडा एंड बहुत
जल्द हम एक मीटअप भी ऑर्गेनाइज करेंगे
दिल्ली में डेल्ली नोएडा कहीं पे भी कर
सकते हैं एंड आई विल अनाउंस दैट मीटअप
थ्रू वीडियो तो आई विश एंड आई होप कि आप
में से मैक्सिमम लोग वहां पे प्रेजेंट हो
पाएंगे टाइम निकाल के अपनी कीमती वक्त
निकालेंगे
राइट
सर मुझे सब कुछ सीखना है इसलिए मैं सब कुछ
सीखना सीखने लगता हूं बट कंप्लीट नहीं कर
पाता हूं एक-एक चीज स्टेप वाइज चलिए एक-एक
चीज को सीखिए कंप्लीट कीजिए आप सब कुछ
सीखने के चक्कर में कुछ नहीं सीख पाएंगे
यह होता है बहुत लोगों केस बहुत लोगों के
साथ तो प्लीज यह वाला अप्रोच छोड़
दीजिए नेक्स्ट क्लास कब होगी दो-तीन दिन
के गैप में होगी जैसे ही मैं फ्री थोड़ा
हो जाता हूं नेक्स्ट क्लास आ जाएगी राइट
टेंशन नहीं लेना थोड़ा वेट कीजिए तब तक
अपॉर्चुनिटी की तरह लीजिए नेक्स्ट क्लास
के पहले और नेक्स्ट क्लास के पहले आपके
पास देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स लाइव सेक्शन
में जाइए यहां पे एंड यहां पे बग बाउंट की
क्लास 22 तक आप क्लास वन से 22 तक कंप्लीट
इसको पूरा कर लीजिए क्योंकि नेक्स्ट क्लास
से पहले आप इसको कर लेंगे तो ज्यादा बेटर
रहेगा ओके
चलिए
youtube1 हुए थे रिसेंटली में वही हुए है
बस और कुछ नहीं वो आएंगे शायद मार्च में
उसके अलावा कोई पैसा भी नहीं आ इस चैनल पे
$100
ओनली सर मैं क्लास 12थ में हूं एक कॉमर्स
स्टूडेंट आफ्टर 12थ क्या करूं साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के लिए सबसे पहले तो कॉमर्स
वाली पार्ट को हटा दो ट्राई करो बीसीए कर
लेने का ज्यादा बेटर रहेगा क्योंकि बाद
नहीं तो बाद में स्ट्रगल्स बहुत हैं बहुत
सारे स्ट्रगल्स हैं डेनिक्स की वेबसाइट कब
तक अवेलेबल हो जाएगी अरे देखो डेनिक्स
वेबसाइट पे डेनिक्स का वेबसाइट डाउन है
मतलब मेंटेनेंस में बट
academy.com ये जो हमारा सब डोमेन है वो
आपका एक्सेसिबल है जहां पे आप आके कोर्स
अगर आपने लिया है तो आप कोर्स में लॉग इन
करके कोर्स को स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं तो
academy.com बिल्कुल एप्लीकेबल चल रहा है
हमारा साथ में de.com वेफ अगर आपको
सर्टिफिकेट वेरिफिकेशन करनी है तो ये पेज
भी आपका मेंटेनेंस मोड में नहीं दिखेगा ये
पेज भी आपका एक्सेसिबल है तो यू कैन गो
एंड गेट योर सर्टिफिकेट्स हियर तो ये
दोनों आराम से एक्सेसिबल है दोनों पे आप
चल सकते हैं साथ में हमारा जो एथिकल
हैकिंग कोर्स का लैंडिंग पेज है यह भी
एक्सेसिबल है तो आप यहां पर आके इस कोर्स
में भी आप इनरोल कर सकते हैं डीसी जीएसपी
के अंदर में सिंपल यहां पर आइए पूरी डिटेल
चेक आउट कीजिए क्लिक कीजिए इनरोल कीजिए
एंड बन जाइए डीसी जीएसपी जो कि एक
क्वालिटी एंड मतलब टॉप नोच कोर्स है जहां
पर आपको बेसिकली स्किल्स मिलेंगे कांसेप्ट
मिलेगा कुछ भी कचड़ा नहीं
मिलेगा आई कंप्लीटेड डे 11 थैंक यू सो मच
फ्रॉम नेपाल वेलकम
ब्रदर
सर सच में आपका क्वालिटी कोई नहीं दे सकता
बग बांटी के लिए थैंक यू थैंक यू
लोस बिहार में भी कभी मीटअप रखिए जरूर
रखेंगे जरूर रखेंगे जरूर रखेंगे न आखिर आई
थिंक तुमने इसलिए पूछा होगा ना कोर्स को
एक्सेस करने के लिए शायद तो मैंने
डायरेक्ट तुम्हारी क्वेरी को सॉल्व कर दी
कि यह वाली एडमी कॉ इ
एक्सेसिबल नहीं आई और वीडियोस शायद नहीं
आएंगे आई देखो जो कांसेप्ट मैं सिखा रहा
हूं उन कांसेप्ट प वीडियोज आती जा रही है
खत्म होती जा रही है जैसे आई की वीडियो आई
खत्म हो गई व वो अब नहीं आएंगे वीडियो
आईडी प और भी ज्यादा लेकिन जब हम बग बाउंट
हंटिंग करेंगे लाइव हंटिंग करेंगे ना उस
टाइम प जब जब हम आईडिया को टच करेंगे तब
तब और भी कुछ चीजें आपको सीखने को मिलेगा
तो लाइव हंटिंग जब होगी तो उसमें भी आप
प्रेजेंट रहिएगा उसमें भी आपको बहुत कुछ
सीखने को
मिलेगा
ओके चलिए ओके गाइस देन आई थिंक इट्स टाइम
टू क्लोज एंड एंड द लाइव बिकॉज इट्स वन आर
एंड माय टाइम जो विंडो थी वो खत्म हो चुकी
है मेरी एंड नाउ आई हैव टू लीव अ बिकॉज ऑफ
द टाइम इश्यूज थोड़ा सा टाइम कम है मेरे
पास तो आज का सेशन काफी इंटरेस्टिंग रहा
काफी मजा आया आप लोगों के साथ काफी सारे
क्वेश्चंस मैंने यहां पे पिक किया आपके
कुछ डुप्लीकेट क्वेश्चंस और कुछ ऐसे जो
नॉन रिलेटेड थे मैंने इंटेंशनली उनको
नेगलेक्ट कर दिया उनको इग्नोर कर दिया
टेंशन नहीं लेना है और कुछ जेनुइन
क्वेश्चन जो छूट गए हैं अगर तो उसके लिए
आप एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी मैं बोलता हूं
नेक्स्ट लाइ सेशन में नेक्स्ट डाउट सेशन
में आप वो क्वेश्चंस लेके आ सकते हैं एंड
हम उसपे बात करेंगे डिस्कस करेंगे उसको
सॉल्व करने की कोशिश करेंगे ठीक है तो आज
के डाउट सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही एंड जो भी
मीटअप्स जो भी चीजें होंगी आपको
बेसिकली
की तरफ से आप इसको स्टार्ट कर लीजिएगा यू
विल गेट अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स ठीक है अ ये
रिपोजिटरी है आपके गिट हब के ऊपर में
साइबर सिक्योरिटी टोनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
रोड मैप ये ऊपर में यूआरएल है आप यूआरएल
को ध्यान से देख लीजिए इस रिपोजिटरी को
आके एंड आप इसको स्टार्ट कर लीजिएगा
बिकॉज़ दिस रिपोजिटरी इज गोइंग टू बी अ
लाइफ चेंजिंग रिपोजिटरी फॉर यू इन टर्म्स
ऑफ नॉलेज एंड स्किल्स यहां पे आपको बहुत
सारी चीजों का रोडमैप जो है ना मिलने वाला
है आने वाले टाइम में बहुत खतरनाक रोड मैप
मिलने वाला है तो यू विल बी बेनिफिटेड
लाइक यहां पे आपको राइट अप्स देख रहे हो
आप सीटीएफ प्लेटफॉर्म्स आप देख रहे हो
यहां टूल्स देख रहे हो और देयर आर मल्टीपल
थिंग्स दैट इज गोइंग टू कम इन दिस सेक्शन
ठीक है जैसे मैलवेयर एनालिसिस के अंदर में
अ प्लेलिस्ट आपको यहां पे कुछ मिल जाएगी
यहां पे एंड्र पन टेस्टिंग के अंदर में
यहां पे वेब पन टेस्टिंग के अंदर में और
भी बहुत सारी चीजें जो आपको मिलेंगी और भी
बहुत सारे रिसोर्सेस मिलेंगे ठीक है सो
दैट्ची सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द डाउट सेशन एंड
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लाइव डाउट सेशन में
हमारे सेकंड डाउट सेशन में बहुत जल्द जब
भी होगी मैं अनाउंस करके बता दूंगा जरूर
आइए ठीक है एंड सबको शुभ रात्रि
एंड हैव अ गुड नाइट शुभ रात्रि एंड मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में थैंक यू सो मच गाइस
टाटा